so I feel like at the end of a show like
this it's just one question you need to
ask yourself what do you believe and are
you prepared to meet it American Gods a
season one at the very least obviously I
am behind on this I have not caught the
show up to this point but I was
commissioned to review it it's been on
my to-do list for a while but like so
many things that have been on my to-do
list for a while the best way to get me
to get her out of them is for somebody
to pay me to do it and they have done
and I am oh I was really happy with this
so I am only gonna be talking about
season one it's been out for a little
while so I am gonna talk spoilers pretty
freely so be warned that in that case if
you yourself have not yet seen it and
you intend to I recommend it and that's
kind of where I have to leave it so I
have read the novel American Gods it was
a while ago
and my memories of it are a little
patchy it's more impressions and a
couple of key moments I don't remember
it top to bottom it's not one of my
favorite Gaiman books I think largely
because it it has sort of that
travelogue feel to it because it is it
is a road trip a big chunk of it and
while that gives you lots of
opportunities to meet all these
different gods and have all these
different locations and encounters it
does give it a less of a of a narrative
flow it felt more like a novel length
exploration of a urban fantasy world
then it felt like a proper narrative
sometimes and that's not necessarily a
bad thing and it's something you
generally get away with in a novel more
than you certainly couldn't say a film
so I think still think it works but
first things as far as like an actual
story I actually vastly prefer and not
see boys which is the semi follow-up
sort of thing but I definitely love the
concept of American guys I've always
loved the concept and I do like a fair
number of the characters so I was really
interested in especially knowing that
Bryan Fuller was involved behind the
scenes the other Michael Green the other
showrunner for the first season has also
done good work but he's you know
primarily was a writer for things that
always felt very director driven and you
know I because I'm more familiar with
his film work fans TV work but Bryan
Fuller the guy behind Hannibal oh yeah
oh yeah that's that's a solid fit I'm uh
I want to see that and boy am I glad I
saw that so boy where do we begin
if you haven't read the book I'm not
gonna say you can't get enjoyment out of
this but you are gonna be in for a
massive head trip having the book is a
little bit like having a cheat sheet
it's not exactly like knowing exactly
what's going to happen because there are
parts that have been expanded parts that
are going different directions whole new
characters who aren't even in the the
book at all so there's so plenty new for
you but you you have your feet under you
because you know the premise you know
what's going on ish as a general sense
of the world where as you come into this
cold you got to be prepared to do some
work to wrap your head around this and I
I'd like to imagine that if that had
been me and I hadn't read the book first
that I probably would have had fun doing
that but even as someone who's read the
book like oh I'm just enjoying watching
all these things just be so fully
embodied by first of all the cast wow
this is an amazing cast I mean it
probably did their benefit that some of
them some of the parts are played by
much bigger actors than you would have
expected largely because they have
fairly
short appearances in maybe two out of
eight episodes or you know maybe four
but they're not in every episode and
their scenes are fairly isolated that's
how you get end up with getting people
like Gillian Anderson and Peter Stormare
and Crispin Glover for relatively short
parts but there the presence of those
kinds of people across the thing that
just gives a nice vibe Kristin Chenoweth
there's another one that just gives a
really nice vibe to the thing overall
that's just really enjoyable and then oh
boy I know a character who's gonna start
talking about her whole life we're gonna
stick a pin in him we'll come back to
him I want to build him looks like my
shadow for a bit my memory of shadow
from the book is very half-formed
I don't have a very strong sense of him
and I don't know if this is if this is
just me or if other people find this I
actually tend to find more often than
not I find a hard time feeling that
narrators or characters whose we get
inside their heads I have a hard time
feeling the characterization for them
often versus other characters and that
was the case a little bit for him
because like I've talked some people and
some people had a much more fully formed
sense of who shadow was then I remember
him being in my mind he was a little bit
of a blank slate is an overstatement but
he was very malleable and he was by far
the most normal thing and person in most
of the situation's he was in which made
him the POV the fish out of water but
also made him comparatively the boring
one so shadow in the book never left
much of an impression on me shadow in
the show works better though I think a
lot of that just has to do with the
injection of personality that a
charismatic carries matter care is
mattock actor brings just by simply
standing there you cast a role like that
well suddenly just looking at somebody
say one line I got more personality eye
shadow than I did for probably
chapters worth of the book just cuz of
one an actor can convey with so little
screen time if they're really good for
the part which he definitely is Laura's
an interesting character for me to talk
about because she is a character and
again not having read the book in a
while I don't know how much of this is
alterations done to the character from
the novel to the show and how much of
this is just me being older and having a
better grasp on the kind of character
she is but I got Laura way better here
than I did in the book and the book she
was just kind of there I actually had
kind of forgotten she was for a bit
until the show started and like she
first got introduced I'm like that's
right she's gonna come back and I but I
kind of forgotten that hadn't stuck with
me as much and I don't think I got Laura
as a character but if the show is
representative of her then she's a she's
the kind of character that I wouldn't
have gotten at a younger age you know I
I wouldn't have understood Laura who she
was what she's about reading it over ten
years ago which was when I did so that
watching it now I really I appreciate
the depth of Laura there's a lot to her
there's a lot going on with her and
there's a lot that has to be conveyed
because she's kind of a horrible person
and she's not fun horrible that's mad
Sweeney we'll get to him she's not a fun
kind of little bit of a horrible person
she is a damaged kind of person and yet
I still really enjoyed her I enjoyed her
presence I wanted her around
I wanted good things for her even though
I'm not sure she deserved any of them
it's a really tough balance to have a
character be someone who you root for
but who's not a good person but isn't
like the fun chaotic kind of not good
person that's tough to pull off that's
tough to write that's tough to perform
that was really really well done across
the board for her since I mentioned him
mad
me hahaha my sweetie is such a small
part of the book actually I've watched
some of the behind the scenes stuff and
they basically admitted to the fact that
once they cast this actor they expanded
the part like we got to do more with him
oh boy am I glad they take especially
paring him off with Laura which the two
of them and has seen these two terrible
people just wiping each other up oh it's
great and he's got such terrific
presence he's just so over everything or
at least he wants to be over everything
you get the sense that he he's the kind
of person person that if you were to ask
him he'd say no I don't care about
anything I don't care about anybody I'm
only out for myself heck with everything
that's what he'd tell you and that's
probably what he wishes were true but
it's not and that I think annoys him
because it probably makes his life more
difficult that's the vibe I got of him
and I enjoyed the heck out of her like
how take toffee is at everything so he
was a lot of fun I enjoyed him a lot I
liked the expansion out from the scene
of the gin which first of all that was a
gorgeous scene that was a that was that
was a wonderful beautiful scene that
could have been super exploitative
actually the show as a whole has a
number of characters who could be super
exploitative I don't feel any of them
work I don't make that call for other
people um but and and and that is one of
them and that oh that worked I worked
really well I I loved the pace of that
scene I loved it that it slowed down and
we got that nice prolonged scene of the
of those two men together that was great
that was really great but the character
who I stuck a pen in what I said I would
come back to Ian McShane could there be
a more perfect Wednesday then he am
ashamed
I don't think so he is gruff yet
charming he can appear like he can
almost fade into the background
sometimes and seem innocuous but there's
always the sense of power behind him and
he God he can do so much but just a look
and I quickly rattled off line but then
he could also turn on a dime when he
wants to even change just great in
general but he is so good for this part
holy crap and the thing is really
honestly so much of the appeal of this
I mean Wednesday was character why I
remember better than I think almost
anybody else and if this show was gonna
work at all it needed a Wednesday who
you could believe in who you could
believe had that much history who you
could believe had that much power who
you can believe was that Wiley and Ian
McShane I believe it I believe a 100% oh
my god so good honestly and this is a
rarity for me if you've been around this
channel for a while I don't really have
any complaints to make about this as an
adaptation I think it's amazing I
suppose like I would say some of the
added material I'm not it's not bad but
I think some of the weaker stuff so like
the stop off with Vulcan that's new
that's completely new and that wasn't in
the book and it's okay it feels a little
more on the nose it feels a little bit
less nuanced then a lot of the other
stuff does on the other hand the stuff
at the end with Easter that was great
and and the way so much of that goes
that's all new and so that was terrific
dug the heck out of that oh I almost
forgot to bring up talked about an actor
who I would not have thought to cast in
this part but was perfect or
Oh Jones as Anansi I know it's mr. Nancy
and but like I can't help but think of
him as a Nancy cuz that's the God he's
portraying oh you're so good especially
first episode he's in the the flashback
like orogeny kind of thing where he's
firing up these slaves in the hold of a
ship
he went from suave to a little yellow a
little bit silly even to dark and cold
and angry and yet keeping that vibe of
let's make this a good story I've
actually thought for a long time that
Orlando Jones was was an underutilized
underrated actor and I feel really nice
to be validated on that cuz uh he's
really good like I said no major
complaints like just tiny things like
tiny things like oh maybe that wasn't
the strongest bit of this but I'll tell
you what I am nervous though because I
wasn't just commissioned for season 1 I
was also commissioned for season 2 and I
know that season 2 had a very very
troubled development and it had a
different show runner who was fired and
then it had a different set of show
runners and they had less money to work
with because the first season went over
budget which looking at it I believe
something looks this stunning I'm not
shocked that it went over-budget but I'm
nervous to see season 2 especially after
such a I'm astounding splash of a debut
that this is I enjoyed the heck out of
this it is wonderful and bizarre and
just you just kind of sink into it as a
world and you just get to dwell in this
space and it's awesome and I am
so scared to see a second season because
I do not want to see this fall apart
we'll see what happens
that'll be out next week wish me luck
and American Gods Season 1 have you seen
it what did you think about it whatever
you thoughts are drop something on down
in the comments let's talk about it and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking all the way through
and for tuning in there's all the usual
stuff you can do to help me out and keep
the channel growing and appease the
Almighty algorithm for we must all
worship those of us on YouTube so you
can like subscribe hit the bell leave a
comment also I naturally have a patreon
and there's gonna be a link for that at
the end here there's blong down in the
description and these lovely names
you're now seeing go past you they help
keep this channel going your name could
be among them but you also don't have to
do any of it because at the end of the
day you are the key soul I just run the
meetings does that mean that I worship
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]